[Music]
okay everyone hello and welcome to this
lecture on the secret light before well
and it's not so secret the secret life
of ponds what it's it's more like to say
that the secret ambition of ponds all
the ponds ever really want to do is
promote that's the secret life of ponds
is promotion and I remember I was very
lucky I was raised in Seattle and there
was a chess scene its what wasn't the
strongest chess scene in the world but
there was a lot of expert of master
players and I was fortunate enough to
have as an early mentor teacher a man by
the name of Jeffrey Parsons and Jeffrey
was about the 1700 rated player and he
really really loved end games and he
introduced to me the concepts of pawn
breakthroughs and he showed me this
position and I remember very clearly he
loved teasing me with these kinds of
very practical chess endings and he said
white white can win this position and I
thought that yet it felt like maybe
white should win this position his pawns
are all the way up the board and his
King position is better than his
opponents the black King position so
sure
it should win for white and you know
immediately to show my brilliance
intuition and deep understanding
I played king c5 with the idea of
bringing my king to d6 and he went King
to c7
King came here and Kim came here and it
was a standoff and I couldn't win the
position so my very first move was a
mistake and this is called a
breakthrough and have you are you all
familiar with this breakthrough for
white that what white does is he plays
g6g sex and oh by the way I wanted a SAG
couldn't solve the position at all and I
wasn't even close i I never even
considered this move because when I
looked at it with the eyes that I had
the understanding I had it appeared that
I was just trading pawns and I didn't
understand I mean he had to show it to
me like three times before I got it
right and the idea is no matter which
pawn black captures with white oops
excuse me white is able to create a
breakthrough a passer
oh that's a nasty little move isn't it
and if you if you take this one then I
push the other and it goes home and then
if you play after this one if you take
it like this I push this one and it goes
home
notice that the King is out of the zone
of the pawn and cannot prevent me from
queening the secret life of a pond
wanting to promote itself to a queen so
if we understand that then we understand
that my first move which by the way I
was very insistent about I I said okay
that move is right and that move
immediately gives up the win because now
after this this this this the King is
inside the zone and now I'm loosing so
my first move King c5 which I was
absolutely sure about allows blacks King
to get close enough to the promoting
pawn and these pawn breakthroughs are
really a lot of fun when you can get
them to work it's fantastic and I have a
I have many examples in my chess
practice over my career but the one that
I really like to show and it's quite
complex I was black so of course I'm
playing for the US Olympic team and my
team members are all watching this game
and this game had gone on very long and
it was very important
for the team success that I do well in
this game okay so I'm black and I'm in
this ending and it's my turn I'm
analyzing two moves the first move is
because I belong to pong grubbers
anonymous is I want to win a pond so the
first move I'm looking at is oops I did
something wrong just a second I think I
think I put it on white to move yeah let
me just okay so the first thing I'm
looking at is grabbing a pond I want to
go rook aged five King b4 and take upon
but the more I look at this the more I'm
not very happy about the fact that my
opponents pass pawn has C pawn is really
strong in fact he's got really good
counter play and maybe he's going to
bring his rook down with a check maybe
he's going to bring his King down and
escort his pawn to the promotion and I
began to feel like White's even though
White's upon down he's not worse that
his his counter play is really severe
okay so then I started analyzing the
ramifications of trading rooks and going
into it King and pawn endgame but we're
all told don't go into a King and pawn
hang game where your opponent has a
passed pawn on the Queen side and you
don't because your King is going to go
to the Queen side to hold up the pawn
and his Kings gonna go over to the King
side and he's gonna eat all your palms
but as I was looking at this King and
pawn
game a thought occurred to me of the
breakthrough the pawn promotion
breakthrough and I had an epiphany and I
saw the game variation all the way to
the very end it's a rather deep
combination of moves a forcing move but
it has a wonderful flow to it and it
just happens to be perfect for our
lecture okay rook check okay well no
choice in this matter
King b3 rook takes King takes now again
all the classics will tell you don't do
this
White's pass pawn white will bring his
King to the King side your King will
have to deal with the past pawn and
you're gonna lose the game
so my teammates were not very happy they
saw me make this decision however I had
calculated that after this very natural
knows that I would be able to keep my
opponents King at bay in other words the
King would not be able to penetrate on
the Kings side
I played 'if I've came here and f5 so
now my king my opponent's king cannot
enter through efore can't enter through
f4 can't go all the way back to f1 and
h3 he I've got this wonderful invisible
barrier that he cannot penetrate but on
the other hand
after king c3 I can't drop back with my
King either if I try to drop back with
my king he'll advance his King and in
advance his pawns so I can only play
pawn moves from this point onwards I
calculated as follows
efore so he could play King to d2 but
after King takes King here I have dude
to do King King King King King King King
King King no I go here here here here
here and I'm going to engineer a
breakthrough with f4 okay so he can't
afford to give up his pawn
he has to play King b3
okay
and now this is this is where when I
traded rooks I'm still down to pawn
moves only right should I make the move
h6 or should I make the move h5
age six fine so the question is where do
I want his king when I start to engineer
my pawn breakthroughs in keeping in mind
the lesson that Geoffrey Parsons told me
you want the king away from the king
side where the pawn breakthrough is
being made h6 King c3 h5 king b3
I in in in my book winning chess endings
I had given a variation that went like
this that white could not give up the
pawn because after King c3 King here
King takes King d2 King takes kingi -
King takes e4 King takes f2 king of to
King G to King g5 King takes King takes
I gotcha
my pawn will be the lone g4 pawn will be
the hero
so II for H 6 H 5 king b3 okay so now
the table is late okay if you take the
pawn on f4 I will play well let's put it
this way I think he had to accept the
pawn yes okay
f4 now if he doesn't take the pawn let's
say he plays the move King c3 what would
be blacks answer
III tags which pawn takes on g3 pawn
takes on gh4 takes and away we go there
we go that's your pawn breakthrough ok
so just a second King is on f4 yes G
takes f 4 and now obviously III takes H
4 simple so easy winning the pawn can't
be stopped but that's too simple but
that wouldn't be much of a lecture thank
you for coming
there's my pawn breakthrough how genius
I am now comes the problem
oops oops
so now if I advance my pond he's going
to take and he's going to advance his
pawn to f6 and he's threatening to
promote so for example if I play g3
--tags --tags he promotes with a check
oops I'm worse
I'm worse so let's go back to this
moment f5 if I play g3 takes takes f6
King c-5a King d6 in order to stop the
pond c5 check what the heck is going on
King u6 e six oh my goodness if I push
he pushes he's threatening the Queen we
check I go here he goes here I queen and
now he Queens with check
oops I'm worse Oh
so why would I trade rooks and go into a
worse ending because I start with King
d600 now if he goes c5 check I just take
it he pushes his pawn and I return my
King to pick up the f-bomb now if it's
my turn I'm just going to go g3 okay at
this point my teammates all run out and
they've seen me play the move King d6
but then they return with worried faces
my opponent plays the move team before
oh my oh my now if I play g3 --tags
--tags check King bush
if I push push Queen Queen what white is
better if I go back push push push
takes or push doesn't matter and
actually it does I should have pushed
this one oops oh sorry I should have
pushed this one threatening the Queen
with check Oh
so my opponent plays the move King
before and it's my turn and my teammates
rush out again what move did I play h3
is very intriguing mood but then he is
going to play c5 with a check bravo
Bravo Bravo king is a king Nephi a pity
I'm not giving out you know prizes for
best comment now the point is is that
after king e5 I'm still in the square of
both pawns c5 I can take and in this
moment I'm threatening g3 so there's
really no choice for for black he has to
play c5
okay I cannot play g3 because he's
threatening to play c6 I take c6 I have
to return King e6 King be five so now
white wants to go King b6 c7 King b7 and
Queen Wacek what are you gonna do King
d6 king b6 sorry
which King e7 King b6 o King e7 King b6
King d8 King b7 he's ready to escort his
pawn home sorry King d6 King v6 if if I
move my pawn he moves his pot and he's
faster
g3 Bravo that's what I played context
now what do I do
h3 correct pawn here King here came here
pawn here check just before he could
clean check so a nice little 21 move
variation that came from a very very
nice ending so one of the nice ideas in
these let me do it again this is a very
typical situation we can imagine the
Kings have been out dueling one another
you know in opposition and things like
this and you're white and on the surface
it appears that everything on the King
side is equal so you you're thinking man
if I can go over here and grab his pots
just let me just let me slip my King
into the position win the game but you
notice that as you're trying to enter
blacks position blacks King is keeping
you out okay that won't do it so you're
thinking to yourself well I guess the
game is a draw
I give up at the game it's the draw
until you become aware of pawn
breakthroughs okay so now we start to
think how do we create a breakthrough I
have to make sure I've put the Kings far
enough away
from one another what you would like to
do is play f5
so let's say that black goes King here
what would you do with white g5
oh it doesn't work g6 font eggs fun
oops the kings and the kings in the
square you think g5 first okay g5 first
came b7
it still didn't work
ah like what's wrong with you this is
not working so how many of you would
like g5 how many of you like f5 okay
let's see g5 one more time to find king
b7 g6 no choice here I got to take that
guy no choice
Black is Riddick
and now the lecture is a secret life of
a pawn but it easy well V you know the
misery of a Cubs law in the mysteries of
the club players so sorry we were good
we were looking at g5 and King bisa
tough tough tough
so what are we going to do with white
mm-hmm g6 as before takes tanks King c6
and black because the pawn breakthrough
is not working though that the king is
well in time and by the way black pawns
are now coming okay so let's take a
leather look at the original move that
we rejected f5
let's imagine King d7 is there another
way of making a pawn breakthrough came
b5 King b5 King c7 or King c4 king c5
maybe king c5 king daeso
King b6 now let's see can i play f6
oops blacks king is closer to the action
than whites King oops let's go back
let's go back to this position we played
f5 King be 7f the pawns on f5 f6 Bravo
Bravo
f6 takes takes King c6 and now g5 the
pawn breakthrough oh these are really
running yeah these are really wonderful
in games where you have these these pawn
breaks so if you're inexperienced and
you just imagine if you just look at
these structures of these eight pawns
you think they're mirror images of each
other and that neither side can do
anything but then when you see when
somebody points out to you that oops
that
so which move and the first one f-five
as before
paan takes here okay like something like
this yes ah
and then came v6 that's a nice way of
winning the opposition and this would
win the game yeah because there's no way
of stopping the king from front row from
attacking let's go back for a moment to
this position and we imagine takes
exactly because of the reason that you
gave that you could also win by
opposition
so it takes takes now king b7 how would
you play for white
King King b5 yeah King here King c5 King
here yep
King e7
now what do you do with white
king or king efore I can't go oh is the
board rung because that this would be
the f4 square here King efore King here
waiting and you haven't made progress
what do you guys think of king c6 do you
like this move trying to squeeze the
position
what do you think is that a good move
yes
okay what about this move we want to
take twice
g7
nice huh gotcha just in time okay so
you're trying to squeeze me here
now what did you with what do you do
with white there are here a six
you think blacks should try f6o why'd
you try f6 okay that's an interesting
idea
why should try f6 that looks like a that
might be a winning idea how is the
situation how is the situation I'm not
sure f6 that's a that's a good tricky
move because of opposition again and if
I play g5 tanks tanks
ooh f6 might be a good winner ooh that
might just win Wow
I I didn't see that line when I came to
the lecture I was thinking of a line
like this takes takes King King one of
my favorite situations is like this now
when there's no other pawns on the board
it's day late but in this position it's
not stamping you're compelled to make a
move that you don't want to do no no no
I hate that day and bad and to show
understanding you don't make a queen
right you make the rug so this is the
secret life of pawns and they're always
dreaming about promoting themselves and
you have to look for those examples
where even when it looks like there's
perfect opposition there are ways that
you can break through
[Music]